hello i'm citizen and i'm the government  does this feel  like kind of a dated parody to you what  no this format is the new hotness  no apple hasn't been doing mac pc ads in  over a decade  you know i still have laws on the books  from the 1800s making it illegal to  offend a horse  right right  anyway if you've got a better idea just  fax it to me  cool yeah i will hello i'm a citizen  and i'm the government did you see my  mandate you didn't win by that big of a  margin i can't wait to  ran through my legislative agenda with  my enormous mandate  okay calm down now a third of eligible  voters voted for you i should get a  sports car  so everyone can see how big my mandate  is  you want to see a picture of my mandate  no scent  gross hello i'm the citizen and i'm the  government  it's peacekeeping  [Music]